えー中学高校
夏休みの宿題を終わらせたことが
ありません
はじめしゃちょーです
こどもたち諸君
夏休みの宿題
ドウデスカ？
も、月の半ばなんで
そろそろ夏休みの折り返しなんですけども
あの僕も経験してるんですけども
夏休みの宿題は
ほんとうに
ウゼェ
ｿﾓｿﾓだって
夏休み！
やすみなんですよ！
休みなのに宿題出すってことは
それ休みじゃないじゃないですか！
その夏休みは夏休みっていう
その休みの面目上だけであって
なんでｼｭｸﾀﾞｲﾄｶｻﾗｼﾞｵﾀｲｿｳﾄｶｻ
ﾌﾞｶﾂﾄｶｻ
ｲﾛﾝﾅｺﾄｦﾔﾗｾﾙﾝﾃﾞｽｶ
ｿzﾀﾞﾄﾔｽﾐﾉｲﾐｶﾞ
ｱﾘﾏｾﾝｶｯﾃﾊﾅｼｦ
ﾎﾞｸﾊｽﾞｯﾄ
ﾂﾀｴﾀｶｯﾀﾜｹﾅﾝﾃﾞｽよお
でもね！！やはり
この社会というものは
そういうの許してくれないようになっていますので
結局皆さん
休みなんですけども
宿題や勉強しなきゃ
いけないですよネ？
僕は高校時代もまともに宿題をだしたことは
ありません
黒板に未提出者の欄みたいなとこに
ずっと僕の名札とか
名前が貼ってあったぐらい
ほんとに
宿題をやんない
やつでした
逆に宿題とか全然出さないのに
ﾅﾝｶ全国模試とかでぇ
あのぉ校内1位とかになったときの
ドヤ顔たるや
という訳であの根本的に僕は
宿題いらない派の
人間なんですけどぉ
まそれでもやんなきゃいけない人が沢山いる
特に
小学生とか！
という訳でま
自由研究とかいろいろあると思うんですけどもぉ
オレの記憶が正しければ
みんなねこういう
夏休みのドリルみたいなやつ
配られてると思うんですよ
という訳で今回
ここ最近勉強という
べの字も無いこのおじさんがぁ
完全に脳内もう
パッパラパッピーの
状態でぇ！
夏休みのドリルをぉ
ま中間を取ってぇ
3年生にしたんですけど
ま小学生が渡されるであろう夏休みの宿題を
どれだけ
早く終わらせられるのか
今回検証してみようと思います
しょうがっこうのみんな！
ぜひ
さんこうにしてね～！
もし俺がこれ
10分とかで終わらせることが
出来たらぁ！
小学生のみんなはぁ！
え～、
ﾍｯｗ
まだ、
宿題やんなくて
いいかもしれない
でもオレでね
凄い時間かかったらぁ！
あのみんなスグ！
宿題やろうね！
結構バカだと思うんですけどそれでも頑張ってやってみようと思います！
とりあえず
全部終わらせればクリアということで
これ国語と算数だけなんで
5教科くらいあると多分
これの終わったタイムの3倍ぐらい
掛かるかなと
思って頂いて結構だと思います
ちなみにボクは今から
しょうがくせいなんでぇ
たまにね
おともだちがあそびにくるかもしれないんですけど
夏休みなんで
友達が遊びに来る時間なども
考慮しての
タイムになると
思います
よぉーい！
スタァートォー！！
ﾋﾟｰ
ﾋｯﾋｯ
ﾊｯﾊｯs
ﾊｧｽー
ﾀｲﾍﾝﾀﾞｧー!
hnﾅﾂﾔｽmﾉｼｭｸﾀﾞｲｶﾞ
ｵﾜﾗﾅｲﾖｵｰ！
hｧﾊｧ
(ｶﾁｶﾁｶﾁｶﾁｶﾁｶﾁｶﾁ)
よしやるぞー
本気で
まじで全部終わらせるかんね。
かけ算の決まりぃー
0の掛け算
7ｵｫｎ
ｴーえまって、
何これ
終ったかもしれん
ｴ7ｦｫ
5と
小～学校
めんどくさいなぁ！
ﾅﾝｶめっちゃ細かい計算ばっかり
させらるﾝだけﾄﾞ
３ﾄ３
(たなっち)ｴｲｯ！
あｯ！
りゅーしょーくぅん！
(た)ｗｗｗ
こんにちは～
ごめんいまボク
しゅくだいやってるのぉ！
(た)ねぇ～宿題なんてやんないで
(た)遊ぼうよぉ～
ダメだよｫ
ｵｺられちゃうよぉ・・
(た)ぃいよ
(た)ｲｯｼｭ
(た)一週間ぐらい
(た)遅れても
(た)先生はぁ
(た)なんも言ってこないよ
ﾝだぁめだよぉ
田中せんせ
ｽｸﾞおこるもぉん
kk88・・・
(た)ｼﾞｬ
(た)ﾜｶｯﾀﾜｶｯﾀ
(た)わかったわかった！
(た)分かった分かった！ｗ
(た)わかった！
待って(た)分かった！
りゅうしょうくーんまって！(た)わかった
ｵｋｫなにぃ・・・
(た)ﾜｧﾊw
ｼﾞｬそこまで
がんばるねぇ～☆
(♪～)
はちにちぃ！！
出来たぁ～！！！
(た)パズドラしよ！
(た)パズドラ！
ｳﾝｱｿﾎﾞｫ～！
uuﾝｗ(た)ﾊﾟｽﾞdrｧーｗ
またねぇ～！
ｱﾘｶﾞﾄ
ﾏﾀ！ｱｿﾋﾞﾆｷﾃﾈｪｰ！
やべ。タイムロスヤベェ。
タイムロスやべぇ。
0ｫｰｴｯﾄ
ﾖｫﾝ
ｲﾁｨ
ﾛｸｩ
５倍
ｴｯﾄ…
sｼｔy
ﾅﾅ、7倍
おっけ！
o※ｊ△♀*ｙs･･♂･
６０２！
ﾊｧ･･･ﾊｧ･･･
ﾏｯﾃ・・・
ﾏｧｼﾞﾃﾞ!!やｧｂ
ﾔﾊﾞｲｼﾞｬﾝごれぇ!?!!?
ﾄﾞ↑んだけｱﾝﾉ？！？！！
ﾔﾊﾞｧｲ!!!
終わったわ！！！！！
夏休み終わったぁ！！
ﾋｭｯ　ﾊｧ～～・・・
頭ｲﾀｧｲｱﾀﾏｲﾀｧｲ・・・
ﾏｼﾞﾔﾊﾞｲ･･･
tyWｯﾃｪー･･･
ガチで無理だ。
o※ｊ△♀*ｙs･･♂･ﾊｧ
ｱｧ-･･･ﾊﾞｧｲ･･･
〈ｺﾝｺﾝｺﾝ〉
はぁい
(やふへゐ先生）ｱｯ
(や)江田くん！
ﾊｧﾊｧｈｗ
(や)パズドラしようよ！ｗ
ようすけ先輩待ってください！ｈ
ｲﾏｧ　(や)今日、友達も
(や)連れて来たんだよ江田くん！
ﾄﾓﾀﾞﾁｨ↑？？
ごめんなさい･･･今日、
ﾅｯﾂ休みの宿題がまだ
おわってないのぉー
(や)ｙa ｽ、そうかｧ…ｈ
(や)hﾝ、まｧた誘いに来るよ！
(や)じゃぁ･･･ｈぁﾌｽｩ
(や)頑張ってね！
(や)ｽｩ
(や)www…
一回だけﾔﾛ!!・・・
(や)ｲﾏ･･･ﾊﾟｧｽﾞﾄﾞﾗｯ･･･ｈ
(や)ｶﾞﾁｬやってるじゃん！
ｶﾞﾁｬｧ？
ｲｯｶｲ↑だけやろｫ！
(や)o※ｊ♂△♀*
ｼﾞｬ一回だけだよぉ！
(や)一回だけやろ！
ﾓ仕方ないなぁ～･･･ｈ(喜)
ﾊｧ楽しかった！
マジヤべえ。
無いﾝだよ…
時間がよｫ゛ｫ゛！！！
(♪～)
(トマトクン)ｎｵｫはじめー
(ト)何してんだよー
ﾊｯ、お兄ぃちゃぁん！
おにぃちゃ、
宿題が終らないんだよぉ～！
(ト)そんなの簡単だろー
ｵﾆｲﾁｬｔ、
手伝ってぇ！！
(ト)手伝ってやろぉか！
お兄ちゃんこっちお願い！
(ト)ﾏｧｶｼﾄｹｪｲ！★
(♪～）
ｽｩｈｵ兄ﾁｬん！！
ﾊﾔｸ！！！
(ト)ｗｗｗ
お兄ちゃん！！
早く！！
はやｧく！！！
待ってお兄ちゃん、
遅くない？
お兄ちゃん・・・。
(ト)もうダメだぁ～！！
嘘だろぉぉお？！？！！！
(♪～)
ｼｭｱｧ･･･
うーーー・・・
一学期のまとめだぁ
やっと算数･･･ﾉｫ･･
ｵ゛ｩ゛ｱ゛
ｱｧｧｧｪｵｧ･･･
ｵｪｴｪｪo※ｊ△♀*･･♂･…
(♪～)
算数終ったｧｧ～！！
o※ｊ△♀*･♂･ｫｫｫ…
ﾏｯｼﾞﾃﾞｱﾀﾞﾏｲﾀﾞｲ･･･
つぎはぁ、
国語でぇす
ぼくは、ｋ国語ｫが苦手なので
全部写させて
ｲただぁきます。
(♪～)
〈ﾈｪー･･･〉
うおぁ！！！
(ト)宿題・・・
(ト)手伝ってあげrなくて
(ト)ごめんなぁ・・・
ｳｩﾝ、大丈夫だよー
(ト)お詫びと言っちゃぁなんだけど・・・
うぅん、
(ト)晩御飯持ってきたからぁ
ｱｧ
(ト)これ食ってからぁ・・
(ト)宿題がんばれ～
わかったぁ･･･
夜ご飯大事だもんね・・・
(ト)ｿﾕｺﾄ
わかｯttｱrが…ｔ･･･
ﾊｧ↑
いただきま～す！
(♪～)
ｺﾞｫｔｿｫｻﾏﾃﾞsﾀ!
よっし
よぉし学力診断テスト！
ﾍｪ…ﾊｧ!!
お母さぁぁぁぁぁん！！！！
ｫｫｵｶｧｧｧｱｻｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧｧﾝﾝ！！！！！！！
(やふへゐ)ﾄﾞｳｼﾀﾉ?!
できたぁ！！！！
(や)出来たの！？
ﾃﾞ↑ｷﾀ!!!!
ｵｶｧｻﾝ、ﾔｯﾀｶﾄﾞｳｶﾀﾞｹ
見ﾃ！！！
hﾊｧ
ﾋｨ…ﾊｧ…ﾊｧ…ﾊｧ
(や)ｱｯ、
(や)偉いじゃない！！
ﾔｯﾀｧｧｧ！！！
ｱｰﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯ！！！
ﾌｫo※ｊ△♀*♂aaああああああa･!!!!!!
はい。
(や)ﾊｲ。
えーー、本気で
えー、夏休みのドリル
やってみると、
1時間29分56秒
一時間半！
かかってしまいました
ただ２教！科で
これだったんでー、
社会と理科と、
英語が入って来ると、
ま4時間･･･
5時間ぐらい見といた方が
良いかもしんないですね～
(や)なるほどｄね
(や)でも、1日で
(や)終りますね！てことは
ただやってて
マジで思ったのがぁ、
結構バリバリ答えも写した瞬間も
あったんですよ、
(や)www･･･
バリバリ答えも写したしぃ
お兄ちゃんに協力して
貰ったりぃ
色々ほんとに
全力をつくしてぇ！
多分この
時間だったんでぇ、
小学校のみんなはぁ
ドリルを終るときは
5時間！
みといた方が、
いいと、
思います
あとね、算数がね！
nnﾝﾝマジで
ﾅﾝｶ物壊したくなるくらい
イライラしてきましてー、
ほんとにねぇ、あのぉ
ﾏｲｯ、5時間で終るっ
ていうことを証明
出来たんですけど、
なるべくー、
ちゃんと進めたほうが
いいと、思いました！
小学校のみんな！、
ちゃんと勉強、
す　る　ん　だぁ
ゾ！★
♪ﾃ↓ﾃ↑ﾃ↓ﾃ→ﾃ↓ﾃ↑ﾃ↓ﾃ→ﾃ↓ﾃ↑ﾃ↓ﾃ→ﾃ↓ﾃ↑ﾃ↓ﾃ→
ﾃｰｰｰﾃﾚﾚﾚｰﾚｰｰ
ﾃﾚﾚﾚﾚｰｰｰ
ﾃﾚﾚﾚｰｰﾚｰｰｰ
ﾃﾚﾚﾚｰｰｰ
ﾚｰｰﾚﾚ
ﾃﾚﾚ
ﾚｰﾚｰﾚｰｰｰｰｰ
ｽﾞﾝﾁｬｽﾞﾝﾁｬｽﾞﾝﾁｬｽﾞﾝﾁｬ
ﾃｯﾃｯﾃｯﾃ♪